Although it may sound like, all the problems have been solved by
just selecting the correct architectural style, there are still some issues.
One important one is that for real systems, big systems it may
require more than one architectural style. We call that a Heterogeneous system,
you can imagine for example that the. System might have
some client/server elements that might have a GUI make it reactive. It may be
the combination of a variety of, of, of of different approaches and the systems,
you still have to have an architecture so that, so you have a single concept for
how the system is going to work. Secondly. Some situations, although
they call for having an architectural style, style are very domain specific. For
example, imagine in military context of a particular kind of airplane.
It may be the case, it is the case that that airplane comes in a variety of
variants. However, the control systems for the airplane is pretty much
the same across variance. That is, it shares more than it differs.
In this situation, we call it a Domain-specific software architecture, or
DSSA. Another term sometimes used is reference architecture,
that is the reference architecture describes what's common. And then for
any particular variant, the architecture responsible for
saying what those variants are, and how they're going to be dealt with.
The third issue is one of semantics. It's easier for me, it's easy for
me to lay out and say, a client server is XYZ. But what exactly does that mean?
It's important, and as the field of software architecture evolves,
to get more and more precise definitions of what these styles mean.
Which will then enable, reuse of, of existing solutions.